[Music]
i know why you have this thing i'll
explain it to you later
what this part right here i know why we
all have it
tell us right now yeah okay uh so when
you're
uh when you're being created in your
mama's belly your face is brought
together by different sections so
there's a section here section here and
then a section here
so when these two fuse that's why this
happens that's why clef
palette happens too when they don't fuse
together properly oh and it's like a
vitamin deficiency or something right
when that
is a vitamin deficiency wait what are
you talking about happening oh this part
why we have this little like
dip here because it meets in the middle
yeah that's when it meets yeah
interesting well
this story here is about catholicism
and the fact that the fact that a 15
year old
italian boy might oh no be the pope
be possessed the patron saint of the
internet
what does that mean he blesses the
internet
no like the pope of the internet no it's
the same thing
he's a saint he is his name the duke of
pornhub
no that's ty so this kid
his name was carlo akutis who died
of leukemia in 2006. oh
he died so you have to die to be a saint
there's steps to this okay
so if he was be beatified
beatify are you trying to plan how
you're going to be a saint
so when i die they'll be like that dude
was a saint you know
you know how they talk about you and and
and how they used to be
yeah but this one's like legit like you
know with catholics i need to learn
so beatification signifies that a person
has entered heaven and can
guide those who pray to them that's what
beatification means
hook me up and so uh he has
now been beatified because pope francis
said that carlo he had performed a
miracle
by curing a seven-year-old brazilian boy
of pancreatic
illness because he had came in contact
with
one of his shirts and he had prayed to
carlo
and so that's like the first miracle
that has been like
confirmed and documented by the catholic
church and so you need two miracles in
order to become a saint
so he's on his way to becoming a saint
and great
so this kid that had leukemia wait those
pancreatic cancer pancreatic cancer he
prayed to this
other kid that died yeah and he also i
believe that he touched his shirt yeah
he came in contact with one of his
shirts
so but a saint helps you guys get guided
through heaven
so saints end up like blessing those who
pray to them
and so because carlo has been a
kid that had like you know had a lot of
people pray to him
there's been other people that have
claimed that they have their infertility
cured because they had prayed to carlo
and
the reason why he's such a big deal is
because when he was alive ever since he
was
a little kid um he was
really into like he was a normal kid he
was into video games and like the
internet and all that stuff he actually
created a website
where it was documenting miracles
throughout time
so the catholic church was saying that
you know
he is like he he used the internet for
good
like for pers like for preserving yeah
preserving
he wasn't creating porn unlike all the
other teenagers and stuff exactly
i want to see his website i wonder if it
looks like old school myspace
angel fire yeah ooh imagine an angel
[ __ ]
fire yeah and you come in it's like a
lot of crosses that are spinning
that's what it looks like so it's this
is his website
miracles list that's pretty good yeah
and so like it
it just i wish it was old school man it
shows like miracles by country and so he
he created this website for that purpose
of like documenting all the
what do they say i can't see my eyes
blurry oh it's just it's different
cities and then the dates and then well
first of all the countries and then
cities and then dates and then
once you click on one it'll like it's
very well documented like what the
miracle was and how it was confirmed and
why it's
mm-hmm 14-12 uh yeah can i see one of
the miracles
if there's two miracles then you can be
confirmed a saint
yeah like or you're eligible to become a
saint no you uh that's when the pope
will
give you sainthood but what makes
something like miracle or not yeah and
what what about
saint bernard what miracles
well they used to um beethoven they had
kids
of water they had kegs of water and they
that's america
and they would give it to or alcohol or
something what about
saint paul
i'm a proud wife a proud wife
i'm a proud mother of this offspring yep
to be declared a saint it's called
uh canaanites canada gotta [ __ ]
beautify
then canaanites yeah canonize so
um but yeah so they're saying that he
would be the youngest person
to be good well he is the youngest
person to be
beatified in the modern era you would
find
beatified
this is really interesting because he's
just like an average kid
average kid like of the modern day what
the hell is hella smog in the back
school's alive
i feel like he would have a nickelodeon
show like the modern day saint
yeah he like is cool yo look at that he
has a backpack
he's got great hair damn thick as [ __ ]
wait is that the same picture go back
it's not the same they just what's that
on his shoulder backpack backpack
he likes oh so go go to the next they
kept the backpack on him that's where he
keeps all his miracles
so so in terms of like catholicism right
so
saints they're like the the gateway to
getting you into heaven then
per se well they're the ones that guide
you through through struggles
like saint nicholas so they could like
oh [ __ ]
there's different saints for different
different things in your life that are
going wrong or
yeah for the outlet the catholic church
like each thing like
if you want to buy a home or if you want
to bless your car
or if you like lose your dog or you lose
something or
a family member said
this is so stupid dude i know we see it
this wasn't safe for naught was a safe
nicholas duck
what's yours idiotic input i don't they
talked it i have nothing
saint louise or something i don't know
no that's not funny i have fun too
i'm having a lot of fun i just don't get
it yeah no it's just so
stupid that's why it's so funny you guys
are such comedians that
it goes it goes over our heads yeah you
know it's not even that
it's so funny like it's a comic joke
this joke is like right here dude it's
so
low it's such a bad joke that's why it's
so
dumb it's such a bad joke these guys
were waiting to tell this joke and
that's why it's so dumb
i get it but he's crying
[Laughter]
out santa claus [ __ ] guiding
everybody into heaven
[Laughter]
he can't even talk
what's on your mind nikki we're like
saint nicholas did
perform miracles and then saint bernards
do rescue people in the snow
so i was deserving that it makes sense
to me
yeah true yeah do you believe in
miracles tiff
do i believe in miracles what
constitutes a miracle the statistic of
it not likely to happen and then it
happens
like call me a saying i made this [ __ ]
come seven times tonight oh
i heard of that saint i thought a
miracle was like
man we thought this [ __ ] was
dead that sounds like a miracle and then
they're like
now it's just on the other house this is
the definition of a miracle a miracle is
an event
not explicable by nature or scientific
laws such an event may be attributed to
a supernatural being magic a miracle
worker a saint a religious
leader yeah there's some if somebody
survived cancer then
i wouldn't call that a miracle i would
call that good luck
luck what about the science probability
was against you
well if they can't explain it
scientifically then like you were
supposed to die
then that means that the scientists were
stupid as [ __ ]
but i would say a miracle is if jesus
came down from the clouds right now and
he's like what's up dude
it's a miracle jesus is here right now
yeah you know my brother
uh when he was born i think that he was
he had complications with his birth
originally yeah but he came out okay and
then my dad
prayed to god saying that if you let my
first son live that i'll dedicate my
life to you
and then he became a pastor wow but i
would laugh because i mentioned that
was like [ __ ] he had to just do it
because he's a man of his [ __ ] work
yeah but he that's why he became a
pastor so he went through seminary
school the whole time while he was
running our business so he why did he
bargain so high he could have been oh no
god you let my first son live
and i would donate my first paycheck to
you that's yeah that's all you got to do
but he wasn't [ __ ] in yeah my dad's a
manager he became a minister and
everything he got his master's in
divinity
while while he had can't bargain two i
want masters in divinity yeah that's
that sounds like harry potter wizarding
school yo my dad was a [ __ ] jehovah
witness's worst nightmare because they
would always come to our door
like have you heard of the lord's words
or something like that
yes and then my dad's like cool would
you like to come in i'm a pastor and
then
trap they would be there for like hours
and you could tell they want to leave
but that's like no let's continue
your dad took off all the door in here
no let's go he just takes the door and
he goes
boom breaks it and he's like you're in
here for now so he would sit there and
talk and those people will never once
again ever evangelize
well they got [ __ ] because my dad has
literally read
so many [ __ ] books about christian
theology yeah if you go into our house
there's a four shell stack
every [ __ ] book my dad has read over
like 10 times wow he was that into it
so you bring these people who are very
lackadaisical in their faith and they
come and you see a man who's about that
[ __ ]
it's like good luck bro and i would tell
these people to just leave i'm just like
no we're good just leave and they're
like we would like to speak to your
father
all right your funeral dude and then my
mom will start cooking food because they
know that they're going to be there for
a very long time i'm lucky
your mom's like got his back too yeah
and they're just like okay i'm gonna be
here for six hours
yup i go there for free dinner i got
time today i got time
this is all it takes just talk about
jesus and you can get free dinners from
your mom
they just keep coming over hey would you
like to touch yeah come on they're like
yo that lady's cooking's good
we might have to convert but who cares
[Music]
so
[Music]
you